Hello Freak bitches.
It's unbelievable how much I thought about
this a lot this last year through the
election,
but he's like unbelievable.
How much like that football team
dynamic is just the whole thing. Yeah.
It's like human beings love to get
into a stadium, be like red team,
blue team, identify with one team
and lose their freaking minds.
Literally lose their minds and that's
when they know it's meaningless when they
know it's just about a ball crossing a
line. And this is, this has absolutely no,
we'll still bring God into it. We'll
bring that team into it. All these,
and again you see like with this Trump
thing now that he just stepped on,
me and Jamie were joking around before
we started like a where it's like he,
he liked threatened nuclear war and
insulted Steph curry in in one thought I'd
ever, everyone in America is like,
excuse me, what was that second excuse?
What it's like and,
and both sides like this is just
what gets them interested. Well,
we are a gossip country now.
Like 100% officially.
Like what we'd like is a squabble between
the leader of the free world who was a
reality star and some of the best
basketball players that have ever lived.
Like oh shit hits on flip ball players.
I mean Lebron James is making videos
about the president of being a douchebag.
He's making videos about
all these different people
like expressing their right
to free speech. I saw one
of the tweets that he, uh,
he tweeted out at the
president where it was like,
just kind of like a broken English tweet.
Like he used the word ain't a lot
in it and it's just him verse Trump.
And I just had a moment where I was like,
so this is where the national conversation
is at now. Like, do you remember,
I just remember watching like a William F.
Buckley versus Gore v down
debates and you're like,
how fucking retarded has
our country gotten? Have you
seen those? The documentary?
Yeah. It's amazing. Really interesting.
If you haven't seen it focuses on Netflix.
What is it called? Something I
don't remember. Bitter rivals. Yeah.
No, that's something that's
called bitter rivals.
That might have been a UFC event back
in the early two thousands [inaudible]
Sylvia, three best of enemies.
Best of enemies. Thank you.
Your children did the stupid pattern.
I don't know.
54 obliteration.
Okay.